emilie marsh bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
tout d'abord qu'est-ce que vous inspire
ce nouveau gouvernement
alors j'ai plus l'impression d'être à la
nouvelle matinale de pascal praud
l'heure des pros qu'un remaniement
ministériel avec bachelot et madame
roselyne bachelot et monsieur dupont
moretti est vraiment rien de neuf que
dans l'ancien et on va continuer la même
politique en fait on ne prend on ne
prend acte de rien pas de la crise
pandémique pas de la grève citoyenne des
des municipales et on prend les mêmes et
on recommence
alors justement certains ministres sont
reconduits à leur poste d'autres parts
parmi les départs les plus marquants
celui de christophe castaner on sait que
des membres de votre parti ont souvent
dénoncé les méthodes d'intervention de
la police notamment lors des
manifestations est ce que l'arrivée de
gérald darmanin est une bonne chose
gérard darmanin si on met aussi ce qu'on
voit dans ce gouvernement c'est que les
ministres forts vienne dlr dont viennent
de la droite
donc après attendons de voir mais ça
n'annonce rien de
de positif par rapport aux violences
policières je pense que monsieur
darmanin n'agira pas dans ce sens dans
cela pour afin que les violences
policières cesse parce que c'est quand
même un fléau dans notre pays
donc attendons de voir mais ça n'annonce
rien de positif
est-ce que emmanuel macron est dans la
continuité avec voilà ce ce gouvernement
qui l'a approuvé pour la fin de son
quinquennat on voit vous l'avez dit un
virage à droite il est il est dans la
continuité de
de sa politique néolibérale en entendant
parler colère du peuple
il continue oui puis fait un virage à
droite qu'il assume complètement donc en
fait rien ne changerait il va continuer
sa feuille de route en cassant nos
services publics
en cassant les droits les droits au
niveau du code du travail et en
continuant la réforme des retraites on
sait qu'ils veulent qu'ils veulent la
remettent alors que ça sera une
catastrophe et donc du coup on n'entend
rien et on continue c'est comme dupont
moretti à la justice quand on entend la
présidente du syndicat de la
magistrature dois dire que c'est une
déclaration de guerre cette nomination
enfin c'est aussi un moment donné il
n'écoute macro on n'écoute personne agit
dans sa feuille de route auprès de ses
copains pour ses copains on est dans une
dans un système oligarchique le plus
complet c'est une caricature
jean castex a avait déclaré il ya
quelques jours que la rentrée serait
difficile est ce que on peut s'attendre
justement à des mouvements sociaux dès
le mois de septembre à votre avis et
surtout après l annonce de ce nouveau
gouvernement dès le mois de septembre
même maintenant parce que les les plans
de licenciements il arriva on n'entend
pas beaucoup parler dans les médias
malheureusement mais moi je vois dans ma
région en auvergne rhône-alpes dans le
bassin clermontois c'est une catastrophe
dans l'aéronautique c'est une
catastrophe dans l'automobile c'est une
catastrophe
on laisse partir des usines qui
fabriquent des médicaments on les laisse
dit idées comme famars le gouvernement
ne fait rien donc en fait oui et ils
veulent remettre la réforme des
retraites a au mois de septembre donc
oui il va y avoir une rentrée bouillante
parce que les gens ils n'en peuvent plus
et que en fait pour répondre à cette
crise qui nous arrive il nous faut de la
protection sociale il nous faut aussi la
création d'emplois il faut que l'état
intervienne interviennent vraiment il
faut aussi que des décomptes des
conditionnalités d adam entreprise c
puis possible de donner des chèques en
blanc on voit bien avec airbus
on leur donne des milliards et ensuite
le la
première commande qu'ils font c'est pas
pour air france c'est pas pour airbus
ces pour bombardier au canada c'est
juste pas possible
à moment donné quand l'état il donne de
l'argent à des entreprises c'est pour
qu'ils remplissent leur carnet de
commandes pour des entreprises
françaises
sinon on va faire comment on voit où on
va pas s'en sortir
et puis on dit rien on laisse faire
merci emilie marsh d'avoir réagi sur
notre antenne je rappelle que vous êtes
conseiller régional la france a soumises